ابدا
مساء الخيرات على حضراتكم اتمنى لكم يا رب
تكون ليله سعيده وايام كلها سعيده
الاسئله جت انا كنت عايز اعلق على حاجه
ولكن
الاسئله سريعا
استاذ جمال هل ممكن ان تشاركنا رايك رايك
فيما يتعلق بمشاكل التهاب الاقباط في مصر
ما هي الحلول التي ممكن ان تنفع للحد من
هذه الظاهره وشكرا جزيلا لك انا
يعني اعتقد ان التعبير الانسب لسؤال حضرتك
هو
التمييز ضد الاقباط في مصر كلمه الطاعات
كلمه قاسيه جدا وعاده بتعني معنى
وهذا غير موجود في مصر ولكن الموجود مزيج
من التعصب على التمييز ضد الاقباط وده
مساله علاجها الحقيقه علاجها الحقيقي يعني
للاسف علاج طويل الامد وهو انه الناس
يكونوا اكثر تعليما اكثر وعيا اكثر فهما
مستواهم الاقتصادي اعلى كل ده ممكن يؤدي
في النهايه الى عقليه اكثر تفتحا تدرك انه
يعني لا يمكن ابدا ان تعادي انسان لمجرد
انه يريد ان يتقرب الى الله بطريقه مختلفه
فالمساله مش بقرار مش بقوانين وان كانت
القوانين يجب ان هي تعبر
لكن مفيش في القانون بيقول حاجه ضد
المسيحيين او ضد اي ديانه يعني ولكن هي
ثقافه الناس وممارستها نتيجه نقص التعليم
واللي بيؤدي الى التعصب
تسعى السعوديه وقطر ومصر الى استنساخ
نموذج دبي فممكن تشرح لنا نموذج دبي او
حلقه عن اقتصاد دبي حلقه دبي فكره جميله
بصراحه يا محمد انما انت بتقول لي في
اجابه سريعه للسؤال حضرتك
اغتصاب دبي
هو زي اقتصاد سنغافوره الى حد كبير انت
بتتكلم على بلد عباره عن هبط تجاري مركز
تجاري المركز التجاري دي للملامح عنده
موانئ كبيره مفتوحه تستطيع ان هي تكون
مركز لكل
لكل شحنات التجاره في العالم كل اللي عنده
تجاره وعاوز ينقلها الى مكان تاني اما
بيمر عبر دبي علشان يتزود منها بكل
الخدمات التي لا توفرها موانئ يفترض انها
اكبر يعني لك ان تتخيل انه
السفينه اللي جايه من الصين مثلا او من
الهند يمكن ان هي تنحرف او تخرج بره
مسارها وهي رايحه لاوروبا علشان 700 800
كيلو علشان تدخل جبل علي او موانئ اخرى في
دبي تتزوج بالوقود تعمل الصيانه تعمل كل
ده ثم تعود الى قناه السويس التي لا تقدم
نفس الخدمات بلد مفتوح في موانئ متطوره في
مطارات متطوره في
قوانين اكثر يسرا في نظام بنكي اكثر
انفتاحا فده يعني
بيخلي خصوصا بقى ان المنطقه كانت مغلقه
اجتماعيا مغلقه استثماريا يعني برضو تبين
تعشق جدا وظهرت تجربتها بنجاح كبير ليس
فقط بان هي عملت تجربه اكثر تطورا من اللي
حواليها ولكن كمان لان اللي حواليها كانوا
متاخرين جدا عنها
بتقول قطر والسعوديه عاوزين يعملوها هو
عاوزين يعملوها في ان هم يكونوا مراكز
اعمال يعني الشركات اللي بتشتغل في
السعوديه قاعده في دبي الشركات اللي
بتشتغل في قطر قاعده في دبي اسيست الشركه
في دبي وبتمارس اعمالها من خلال مكتب كده
يعني فرع في السعوديه رغم ان الراجل
والارباح جايه من قتل ابواب من السعوديه
وجايه من مصر لانه بيئه الاعمال اكثر
مرونه
التاسيس الشركات فتح الحسابات الى اخره
يعني
وده جاري تغييره بتحاول تغير ده في الوقت
الحالي امريكا ام روسيا ام الصين ده محمد
بيقول ايهما لديه قوه دبلوماسيه اعلى
وتاثير اعلى يعني هو السؤال يا محمد يعني
مش بيتسال كده يعني لو انت عاوز اجابه على
هذا النحو فما في شك يعني ان الولايات
المتحده هي القوه الاكبر في العالم حتى
هذه اللحظه فلو انت عاوز اجابه مختصره
الولايات المتحده ولكن ده بيتوقف على
الدوله اللي انت بتتكلم عليها يعني الدول
اللي موجوده في بحر الصين الجنوبي هيكون
تاثير الصناعه لهم اكبر لو بتتكلم على
الدول مثلا اللي موجوده في اسيا الوسطى كل
ستان ديت كذا خستان واترككم الى اخره
تاثير الصين وتاثير وتاثير
عليهم اكبر اذا تحدثت عن دول امريكا
اللاتينيه اكيد الولايات المتحده تاثيرها
اكبر
اخبرنا اخبرتنا سابقا ان بعض الحلقات سجلت
ولم تدعى هل تشاركنا بعد الاسرار وبعتني
سابقا بنشر حلقه كانت عن
ماذا لو استمر حكم الاخوان المسلمين
والاسلاميين حتى الان كيف سيكون شكل
الدوله
والله انا يعني
اه يعني هو موضوع مخرج احمد ان احنا نتكلم
فيه ولكن انا بعتقد ان الموضوعات دي ممكن
بخاف اتكلم فيها ما تهمش الناس ولكن بما
انك سالت
احيانا اسجل حلقه وبعدين زي ما حصل في
موضوع فيجنر على سبيل المثال انا كنت مسجل
حلقه يوم خميس اعتقد هنا المكتب بيقفل
جمعه وسبت ما لم يكن هناك ظرف استثنائي
يعني
فانا بسجل جمعه بسجل خميس
وابيع في الويك اند اذا كان هناك سبب انا
سجلت حلقه كانت بتتكلم على محاولات
الولايات المتحده
تقويد روسيا من الداخل الحلقه
كانت مباشره
ولكن لها علاقه بانه روسيا هتبقى على صفيح
ساخن الكلام ده كان كان جاهز كان جاهز
للاذاعه في
يوم
الخميس بالليل او الجمعه فوجئت احداث
فاجنر اللي اندلعت اظن مسائل جمعه وصباح
السبت اي لو انا اذاعه الحلقه دي في
الحاله ديت الناس مش هتتخيل دي حلقه مسبقه
يعني هيبقى فيها حاجه ناقصه ففضلت ان انا
اركها ولم تضع يعني احيانا الحلقه بتبقى
جاهزه تقريبا ولكن احداث تجاوزتها بمعنى
انه بستنى الحدث لما يجي مره تانيه انت
بتتكلم على حدث مثلا ماذا لو حكم الاخوان
القصه دي كانت شغلانه من اربع خمس سنين بس
هي مش بتبقى اقرب الحلقه يعني مش حلقه ان
انا عاوز يعني ببقى عاوزه اثر فيها الفكره
ما انت شيل كلمه الاخوان المسلمين وقتها
كانت الاخوان المسلمين باعتبار اكبر جماعه
اسلاميه
انا كنت مشغول بفكره شغلاني من وانا طفل
دايما في تصور في عالمنا انه احنا اطفال
انه الاسلاميين عندهم برنامج متميز لو
اتيحت لهم الفرصه سوف
يؤدون بشكل مختلف عن الحكومات قليله
الكفاءه الفاسده او حتى بلاش الكلام
الكبير سوف يؤدون بشكل افضل من القوه اللي
موجوده في منطقتنا هي عباره عن قوه عسكريه
يجوز بس هي المساله محتاجه اختبار هل بغض
النظر عن مفهوم الكفاءه اللي هو نسبي لانه
في الاخر الاسلامي ده هو مهندس دكتور
سياسي اقتصادي قد يكون قد يكون هو بس
متدين او عنده تصورات مختلفه في قناعاته
هل
مساله الفساد موجود في كل الناس ما تقدرش
ان انت تحصره في فئه معينه لكن اللي تقدر
تقول ان في فرق انت عندك ايه مختلف لو جيت
تدير بغض النظر عن الكفاءه والقلم مساله
نسبيه وتختلف من شخص لشخص الى اخره يعني
انت عندك ايه مختلف
فالمساله كانت معناها ان احنا هل احنا
عندنا في الاسلام اقتصاد مختلف تماما يقدر
يعمل فرق جوهري هل احنا عندنا مثلا نظام
حكم مختلف تماما انا قنعت لغايه ما نطرح
القصه ديت انه لا توجد فروق لجوهريه كبيره
لو جاءت جماعه اسلاميه تحكم ولو افترضت ان
الجماعه الاسلاميه ليست متطرفه زي طالبان
او ليست مثلا جماعه دمويه زي داعش او غيره
حتى لو افترضنا ده هذه الجماعه التي سوف
تاتي لن يكون لديها فارق يذكر على الامور
الحقيقيه مش تكلمني على فوائد البنوك
وتكلمني على ملابس المراه او تكلمني على
يعني لكن الحاجات الجوهريه في نظام العمل
في النظام الاقتصادي في نظام في نظام
الحكم لا توجد فروج جوهريه اذا اردتم
المزيد المزيد انا تحت امركم
استاذ سيد قناه نعرف
بمناسبه احمد جمال انت بتقول حلقات انا في
حلقات بقى مثلا بتقضي معايا شهور طويله
جدا بغض النظر على المثال اللي انت سالتني
عليه اكتر من مره يعني
بيبقى في ناس بس حلقه ممكن تقعد معي شهور
يعني حلقه الحرب العالميه الاولى اللي انا
قطعتها من حوالي شهر
انا قعدت ثلاث سنين عاوز اعملها طب مش انا
قاعد متفرغ لها ثلاث سنين يعني بس من ثلاث
سنين يعني من جولاي مش ده يعني ثلاث سنين
يعني دايما بفكر اعملها في ذكرى وقوعها
اللي هو
بس لما جيت اعملها من ثلاث سنين انا كانت
فكرتي اعمل فيها ايه ماذا يمكنني ان اضيف
في محتوى عربي الى الحرب العالميه الاولى
اللي وقعت من اكثر من 100 سنه كل ما يمكن
ان يقال قيل انا من رايي مش محصلش يعني
ولكن هو موجود بس عاوز تعب كتير الاضافه
اللي انا كنت عايز اعملها ان انا ابسط
اللي يشوف الحلقه في اقل من 40 دقيقه وفي
حدود النص ساعه يعني يفهم اللي حصل بجلاء
دون ملابس ودون اخلال في نفس الوقت
بس عشان تعمل المهمه دي انت محتاج في
حقيقه الامر تعرف تاريخ اوروبا كله طيب
انا علشان اقعد اقف على الصوره ديت انا
عارف الخطوط العامه علشان يعني استذكر كل
ده
وانظمه عاوز جهد كبير في اول سنه وجدت
العمليه انت مديتنج عمليه صعبه السنه اللي
بعديها افتكرت عاوز اعمل الحرب وجدت انه
فكره المهمه وان انا الخصها في فتره صغيره
وبالمناسبه الحلقات احيانا بعمل حلقه
فالاقيها بقت كتير قوي فالغيها واخد منها
جزء واتجاهلها يعني بعد ما اسجلها بلاقيها
كبيره يعني
الى ان جئنا الصيف ده فقررت انه اوكي يعني
فكره ان انت تابعت الحلقه ما هي الصغيره
اقل من 40 دقيقه بس اللي هيشوفها اظن يعني
تخيلي انه ممكن ياخذ فكره عن تاريخ اوروبا
كله
وبتعقيداته اللي ادى الى الحرب العالميه
الاولى واذا فهم ده وفهم الحرب العالميه
الاولى لن يكون لديه اي صعوبه فقدوا يفهم
الحرب العالميه الثانيه وكل ما اتبعها
يعني
كنت حضرتك بتقول لي استاذ سيد قناه نعرف
اصبحت مؤثره ومرجع للعديد ده معتصم من
الدول العربيه وبدون مبالغه اصبحت مثل
مركز الابحاث الغربيه المؤثره على صانع
القرار ربنا يخليك شكرا جزيلا
وبمناسبه سؤال احمد بمناسبه سؤال معتصم
وانا زي ما بقول لحضراتكم عاده يعني
ما بشعورش بالارتياح في الحديث عن الحاجات
اللي هي تخص القناه وتخصني يعني
ولكن احيانا ما انا بقول لحضرتك مثلا انا
عملت الحلقه دي فخرجت منه جهد كبير انا مش
متوقع هتجيب مشاهدات اصلا لان النوع ده من
الحاجات اللي هي تاريخيه واستقصائيه اول
الحاجات اللي فيها
يعني حاجات مجرده قوي ايه فكره الليبراليه
ايه فكره
لازم في السياسه اللي انا حطيت لها على
مختلفه فيها فكره الليبراليه فكره
الديمقراطيه تطبق ولا لا النوعيه دي من
الحلقات بتحتاج الى جهد كبير جدا لو حبيت
تاصل الفكره وعاده ليس لها جمهور كبير
جمهورها من النخب والنخب في اي مكان عددهم
محدود جدا فتشوف حاجه زي الحرب العالميه
الاولى دي شفائي 160,000 مثلا 150,000
باقل من 200,000 حاجه زي الحلقات اللي انا
اشرت لها ديت هي اخرت اسابيع واحيانا تؤجل
لعده شهور الى ان تكتمل الفكره في ذهني
بمعنى تكون واضحه جدا وقادر انا على
اختصاره ا في وقت قليل انما بيعوضني عن ده
الحقيقه رسائل زي رسائل مثلا الاستاذ
معتصم او من اساتذتي لما حد بيكلمني او من
الناس اللي انا
بحترم رايهم فيقول لي انه والله انه كلام
طيب فبحس ده يعني ايه كان يستحق التعب ما
هو الروبل الرقمي ما الفرق بينه وبين
الراجل الافتراضي
كتير جدا جدا جدا
هي الحقيقه الفلوس اكتر شويه من العمله
الورقيه بس ده قصه يطول شرحها انما ابسط
اجابه انه بدل ما يكون عندك هو نفس عمليه
القواعد اللي بتتحكم في عمليه الاصدار ما
في قواعد بتتحكم في اصدار كمل
الدولار او كم بالجنيه او كمل الدرهم الى
اخره نفس القواعد بالظبط تنطبق على العمله
الرقميه بتصدرها البنك المركزي لدوله
المال تحت سيطرته بيقول باصداره ان هو
يتعهد بانه يحافظ على القدره الشرعيه الى
هذه العمله بنفس كل الضمانات الفرق الوحيد
انها بدل ما تكون ورقه هي عباره عن
ديجيتال انا بركز على الفكره دي لانه في
فرق ما بين العملات الرسميه وما بين
العملات الكريبت والكرنسيز اللي هي قصه
تانيه خالص بقى داخله في عمليه
السيرياليزما والسرياليه وانا اتكلمت عنها
كتير لكن الاجابه المختصره للسؤال يا
صديقي لا يوجد فرق غير زي بالظبط
[موسيقى]
مش عارف اي حاجه واي حاجه بتلمسها بايدك
يعني
فهي هي هي نفس القصه زي ما انت عندك فلوسك
في البيت شايلها في ايدك وزي ما انت عندك
نفس الفلوس ديت هي موجوده في رقم على
او في كارد لا اكثر ولا اقل
قصه تانيه انه قد يترتب عليها مشكلات عند
التوسع فيها في المستقبل بس دي قصه تقول
شرحها بقى يعني انت عند طريقه التحويل هل
هتحتاج نظام سوفت هل ممكن مثلا يحصل عمليه
تهرب من دوله لدوله مش داخل الدوله نفسها
يعني هتنتج عنها يعني مزايا اهي كلها
مزايا وينتج عنها تحديات في النظام المالي
والنظام النقدي العملات الرقميه
هنرجع تاني لنفس الاسئله ممكن حضرتك تعمل
سلاسل مرتبه لتدريس العلوم الانسانيه
للمبتدئين بس كلمه العلوم الانسانيه زياده
كلمه كبيره يعني العلوم الانسانيه بتتكلم
على علم الاجتماع والفلسفه وحاجات كثيره
انا بفكر في حاجه بس انا ببقى قلقان من
يعني من رد الفعل انا بفكر من حوالي سنه
ان احنا نعمل زي ما عملنا نعرف سياسه اللي
هي نعرف دي وعملنا نعرف اقتصاد ان انا
اعمل نعرف فلسفه ونعرف فلسفه الفكره اللي
شغلاني من سنين طويله انه استعين ببعض
المتخصصين لان دي مساله مجهده جدا وهؤلاء
كل واحد فينا يعرض لنا اهم الفكره
المركزيه لاهم العقول اللي في التاريخ او
في العالم الفكره المركزيه اللي كانت شغله
مثلا ابن سينا الفارابي ابن رشد الفكره
المركزيه اللي شاغله
حد زي الا بر محمد عبده حد زي حتى من
المؤثرين من الناس التنظيميائيين زي
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
الفلسفه حتى في عليا بس في الحقيقه انه من
يحكم بالعالم هو الفلاسفه لانه هو عنده
فكره الفكره ديت بيعبر عنها بتتحول الى
شكل الدوله دوله سلطانيه دوله ديمقراطيه
دي فلسفه
يعني الدوله السلطانيه اللي عاشت لقرون
طويله عباره عن ايه انه بنظام الحكم
الالهي ان الملك ده هو رمز الله على الارض
يسال امام الله مش يسال امام البشر
وبالمناسبه بعض الحكام في العرب دلوقتي من
غير ما يقصده يقول لك ده انا مش انا مش
خايف منك انت انا خايف من ربنا انا مسؤول
من ربنا مش منك انت وهو بيعبر عن الفلسفه
القديمه ديت نظام الحكم الالهي
فكر فيها هل ممكن تطبق هل ممكن لا هل ممكن
اجد يعني من الاساتذه اللي ممكن
يتعاونوا معي في دي لو عندكم افكار اكتبوا
لي اذا كانت الفكره عجباكم يعني متى ستضرب
اسرائيل ايران هل اقتربت ده اخونا مد هل
اقتربت بسبب التحرك الامريكي في المنطقه
وماذا سيقع ان وقعت
هل تقصف السعوديه اولا اتمنى ان ما فيش
حاجه تحصل وكلمه مدى ستضرب يمكن يكون
التعبير الادق في هل ستضرب متى دي يعني
انت جزمت ان هو ضرب هو في الجوهر من قلب
سؤالك انك بتقول ان في 3000 جندي امريكي
جمله لمنطقه الخليج ودي حاجه غريبه عجيبه
لانه من ايام ترامب
ومن قبليه احنا عاوزين نخرج من المنطقه
حقيقه الامر ان امريكا
ثبت ليه انا مش قادره تخرج من المنطقه مش
قادره لا قادره تخرج من المنطقه علشان
تركز مع الصين ولا قادره برده ان هي تصيب
الصين لوحدها فهي اوفر ستراشد مرهقه هنا
وهنا وهنا وده شان كل الامبراطوريات اللي
بتكون في يعني في سنوات او سنوات الارهاق
ان هي
الالتزامات اللي عليها اكبر من قدرتها على
ادائها انما بالنسبه للتلات الاف التفسير
الوحيد اللي بياتي في ذهني
هو انه هو بيدم عنده مجموعه اسباب حاجات
شخصيه انه عايز ينجح في الانتخابات اتنين
عاوز عشان ينجح في الانتخابات دي عاوز
يرضي اسرائيل وعاوز يرضي السعوديه اللي هم
اهم شريكين ليهم في اهم الشركات من
الولايات المتحده في المنطقه بالاضافه الى
ارضاء بعض الدول الخليج المؤثره يعني
بالنسبه له حاجه تانيه يريد ان يضغط على
ايران اللي هي البلد اللي هو الاكثر
يعني البلد
اللي عليه شبه اجماع عند كثير من
السياسيين الامريكان بانه ده بلد مغضوب
عليه امريكيه ايه الحاجه اللي ممكن تجمع
كل ده مع بعض انه يرسل قوات هناك اذا ارسل
قوات هناك هو بيمارس ضغط على الايرانيين
ممارسه الضغط على الايرانيين سوف يرضي
الكثير من الاسرائيليين ودول الخليج مش كل
دول الخليج يعني بعد دول الخليج ويثبت لهم
جديه بايدن في انه مستعد انه يتخلى على
المنطقه ومستعد للدفاع
بكليه حقيقين العرض على المصالح
الخليجيه ويقنع الاسرائيليين انه انا
اراقب ما يجري ولن اترككم ابدا عرضه
للايرانيين رغم ان اسرائيل عندها اسلحه قد
ايران ثلاثين اربعين مره
يترتب على الكلام ده ايه في الفتره ديت هو
اقناع السعوديين بتوقيع اتفاق سلام مع
الاسرائيليين لانه الشرط الاساسي
للسعوديين ان انت تمنحنا
اتفاق دفاع مشترك هل يعني ده يعني التفسير
السريع اللي ممكن ياتي للذهمن انه محاوله
لاقناع السعوديين بذلك وبالتالي يبقى يقدر
ييسر الامر هل ممكن ده كافي الاقناع
السعوديين انا اظن السعوديين لم يرضوا
باقل من اتفاق رسمي ممرر من الكونجرس ولكن
ما يفعله الان
له عده اسباب زي ما انا اشرت منها اقناع
السعوديين ان انا جاد تعالوا نقعد مع بعض
بجديه اكبر وما تاجلوش الاتفاق حتى تمنحوا
هذه الميزه الكبيره للرئيس التالي يمكنكم
ان تعتمدوا عليها واذا انا نجحت زي ما
اثبتت جديتي وارسلته جنود انا هوقع معكم
او احاول امرر
اتفاق دفاع مشترك
بيحضر حلقاتك قلت
مرض الاسئله جميله يا عمرو
لماذا التوقيت لماذا هذا التوقيت لانقلاب
النيجر ما هو الهدف لا هو التوقيت فطيمه
ما في توقيت مش غريب ولا حاجه التوقيت
احنا لو حضرتك شفت حلقه النيجر منطقه
الساحه الاولا اللي هي الساحل بالتعريفات
اللي احنا قلناها الدول
العشره اللي موجوده تحت
دول شمال المغرب شمال العربي اسف من مصر
الى المغرب
الدول دي هي
جزء من
الترابيك اوف كيوس او
يعني من مناطق الفوضى من سنين طويله
ونتيجه ونتيجه والفوضى دي زادت نتيجه
الصراع ما بين القوى الكبرى الصين وروسيا
والولايات المتحده
وتراجع نفوض الولايات المتحده ادى كمان
لدخول قوه اخرى زي الهند وزي تركيا وزي
فضلا عن الدول الاوروبيه المتوسطه زي
اسبانيا وغيرهم كل دول كانوا ملجمين حين
كانت الولايات المتحده هي صاحبه الكلمه
الاولى الاخيره وطبعا صديقتها فرنسا كانت
هي القوه المعيمنه بس دي حلفت الولايات
المتحده فالاطار العام انه في حاله سيوله
والدول دي اصلا كانت ضعيفه دول ضعيفه
وفيها اضطرابات وحصل فراغ الى حد كبير على
الساحه الدوليه لازم يكون في انعكاس
الانعكاس ده يكون له اكثر من شكل احد
اشكاله هو انه يكون في انقلابات عسكريه
الانقلاب العسكري ده سببه ايه سببه ان
الدوله ضعيفه الدوله ضعيفه ليه هي كانت
قويه امبارح هي ضعيفه ما منذ ان الدلل
احتلال الفرنسي عليها او الاحتلال غير
الفرنسي
من ستين سبعين سنه وكان دايما في يعني
[موسيقى]
انقلابات الفتره الاخيره زادت الانقلابات
الاسباب اللي انا بقول لحضرتك عليه او
بقول لحضرتكم عليها ووجود فراغ وجود ضعف
وجود صراع بين قوه كبيره ده كله ادى الى
الانقلابات المتعدده انت حضرتك بتقولي ايه
السبب المباشر هو نفس السبب اللي ادى
للانقلاب اللي كانوا في مالي هو نفس السبب
سبب الانقلابين في بوركينا فاسو ونفس
السبب ادى الى انقلاب في غينيا هو نفس
السبب اللي ادى الانقلاب في السودان ونفس
السبب اللي ادى الانقلاب في تشاد كل دول
كل دول احنا بنتكلم من سنه
21 20 21 الى الان فما فيش مفاجات ولا
حاكم واذا اضفت محاولات الانقلاب هتجد ان
دي ظاهره
في الاربع خمس سنين اللي فاتوا
باحدى حلقاته قلت ان فرنسا ده احمد
وضعت الاقليه في لبنان وسوريا في سلطه من
اجل ان لا تقراها ده صحيح مش بس فرنسا هو
اللي حصل انه في اتفاقات سايكس بيكو
فيما يتعلق بهذه المنطقه من العالم وجدنا
انه كانت احد الطريقه اللي فكر بها صناع
القرار وقتها
انما يعني السياسه
كان احد الاعتبارات في ان هم دعموا نخب
حاكمه كان هو ده ان انا اجي مثلا عند
السوريين في سوريا واختار اسره علويه
او ادعم وجود اسره
بعد يعني في بلد زي سوريا والاسره
العالميه ديت هتبقى عندها اقليه هي اقليه
لكن في نفس الوقت هي السلطه سوف تمنحها
قوه فلن يتم الفتك بها الاغلبيه عندهم قوه
الاكثريه لكن في نفس الوقت ليس لديهما
السلطه المثال اوضح في العراق انه السنه
هم الاقليه والاغلبيه والشيعه هم الاغلبيه
فيبقى السنه بتحتني
بالسلطه
[تصفيق]
والشع بيحتموا بالاكثريه
ده هو يعني اللي انا قصدته
تحياتي لك استاذ جبيل افضل قناه يوتيوب
بالمحتوى
بالمحتوى العربي بوركتا اخوك محسن السماحي
ربنا يخليك يا محسن شكرا جزيلا والله الله
يخليك
هل ممكن ان تصبح افريقيا مزدهره يوما ما
وكيف ذلك شوف كلمه ممكن انا اذا ما قراتش
الاسم سامحوني بكون عندي صعوبه في انه
يعني اجمعه يمكن عشان انا عجزت لكن اخونا
اللي كاتب هذا السؤال
الاجابه على اي كلمه سؤال ممكن ممكن لكن
لو بتسالني انا على طريقه تفكيري وعلى ما
يتوفر الي من معرفه محدوده اقول لك لا
يعني لا
مش في مش في الثلاثين اربعين خمسين سنه
اللي جايين الدول دي عامله الدول منهاره
فين دول في دول لها اقوام يعني ايه تونس
ممكن تقوم على رجليها بعد ثلاث اربع سنين
عشر سنين اذا الامور استقرت عشر سنين في
عمر الدول مش كتير في دور ممكن تفضل
متماسكه زي المغرب زي الجزائر في بدون زر
مصر تقدر تقف على رجليها بعد تتجاوز
الازمه دي والازمه اللي موجوده الاقتصاديه
ازمه عنيفه انما مرت بها كتير لكن مقومات
الدوله موجوده وفي دول مقاومات الدوله مش
موجوده اصلا فيها صعوبه شديده يعني
السودان هيعاني كتير جدا والاقرب للمنطق
اتمنى ان لا يتحقق ان يتفتت الى مزيد من
الدول بلد زي النيجر اللي بنتكلم عليه
الدول دي عندها معاناه شديد بلد زي
افريقيا الوسطى عندهم مقاومات الدوله اللي
تخليها تبقى وقويه محدوده جدا
انا هقول لك على رقم صغير بمعايير
النهارده وافرقه اتحسنت الى حد كبير
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لكل دول افريقيا
الاربعه وخمسين اللي هم مسجلين في الاتحاد
الافريقي
3-1 من عشره تريليون دولار ارقام 21
تلاته بواحد من عشره تريليون دولار الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي لفرنسا اللي هي المحتل
القديم لها لوحدها ستين مليون يعني يعني
افريقيا احنا بنتكلم على مليار وحوالي 300
مليون
فرنسا اللي هم حوالي 60 مليون اتنين وسبعه
من عشره تريليون دولار يعني الفرق بين
فرنسا وافريقيا افريقيا كلها على بعض يعني
رقم بسيط جدا
فرنسا مش اقل بكتير من كل اجمالي الناتج
افريقيا
لو سمحت نريد برايك رايك في النظام
المغربي او او البلاد
انا مش انا مش عارف والله انا مش انا معلش
مش عارف اقرا السؤال سامحني بس انت بتقول
لي رايي في النظام المغربي انا مش بقول
رايي في نظم يا صديقي لانه انا مش يعني
انا صحفي من ستريم يعني انا صحفي
يعني ايه في صحفي بمعنى يعني انا مثلا في
اصل في ناس ما شاء الله عندهم قنوات فيها
عشرات الملايين بس هو يعني هاوي انا معنى
انه كده بيتكلم كده يعني لكن انا الكلام
لازم يكون منضبط وانا ما اقدرش ان انا
اقول والله انا رايي ان هذا نظام فاسد
وهذا نظام عادل وهذا النظام عظيم اولا
بسبب ما تقتضيه الحرفه من بطل الكلام
الامر الثاني ان القناه بطبيعتها لا تصدر
احكاما من هذا النوع وانما بتحاول بس هدف
القناه هو بذل جهد في محاوله فهم مواقف
الاطراف المختلفه من قضيه ما
نيجي نتكلم على المغرب ادائها الاقتصادي
مثلا نتكلم على موقف المغرب من ليه هي
علاقتها باسبانيا كده ليه علاقتها
بالجزائر كده ليه علاقتها من قضيه الصحراء
كده ده ممكن نتكلم فيه لكن موقف عام
النظام
يعني عاده هذا لا يدخل في
في شخصيه القناه يعني
لماذا
يواجه هجوما شرسا من القضاء والحكومه
الامريكيه وشكرا وشكرا يا اخونا حمد
في حد رد عليا طيب ايه رايك في الاقتصاد
المغربي
كويس يعني الاقتصاد المغربي قدروا ينجحوا
في امور طبعا هم عندهم مشاكلهم لان هي بلد
ما عندهاش موارد عظيمه يعني
ولكن البلد من الدول اللي هي اذا نظرنا
الى ظروف المنطقه هنلاقي لها واقفه على
رجليه بس لما بقول واقفه على رجليها انا
بتكلم على عليها كدوله يعني ايه كبوله
يعني الناتج المحلي الاجمالي يعني عدد
الصناعات اللي هي اللي بدات تدخل فيها زي
مثلا الطاقات النظيفه زي
زي السيارات الى اخره انما لا يعني ابدا
ده لا يقول كل الحقيقه انت ما بتعرفش
توزيع العادل للدخل يعني لو كان الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي مثلا ليه المغرب حوالي
130 140 مليار دينار ده رقم ما هوش كبير
يعني انما
توزع ازاي في الغالب هيكون التوزيع زي
معظم دول المنطقه انه الفئه الغنيه
المرفهه بتاخد نصيب الاسد والباقي طبعا من
الفقراء والمطحونين فدي مساله في الغالب
لكن انا ما عنديش ارقام تقول ده بشكل جيد
ارقام دقيقه قوي او على الاقل مش متوفره
عن شكل البطاله ومتقسمه ازاي في الريف في
الحضر لكن الاوضاع من بعيد بدون تدقيق في
هذا العالم يعني هو اقتصاد هو اقتصاد جيد
دول ترامب بيلاحق في القضاء
وبيلاحق في كل مكان حمد
حماده حماده
لسببين سبب مباشر ان هو الراجل فعلا متورط
في كل انواع المشاكل يعني ما فيش مشكله ما
تورطش فيها ما فيش ست بقى اتحرش بها ما
فيش كان في
مش تحرش تحرش اغتصاب وتعرفهم للاغتصاب
مختلف شويه عن منطقتنا تهرب من الضرايب
سباب كل حاجه يعني
محاولات تاثير على مخالفه القوانين على
مستويات مختلفه فهو متورط في كثير من
المشاكل بدون اي افتئات عليه لكن يضاف الى
ذلك ان في غيره ارتكب جرائم مشابهه وقفلت
لكن ده صعب ان هم يفلتوه لان هو فعلا انت
يعني ضد المؤسسه الامريكيه يعني ايه
المؤسسه الامريكيه يعني في كل بلد في نخب
بتحكم النخب ديت بتتعايش مع بعض تختلف هنا
تختلف هناك انما عارفين قواعد اللعبه
عارفين ايه حدود الاختلاف فيما بيننا عشان
المركب تمشي ده راجل جاي
يعني تقريبا بدل ما هم كلهم بيقعدوا مع
بعض على ترابيزه يعني يتفاوضوا على
مصالحهم ده جاي يقلب الترابيزه كلها فعنده
يعني لما تيجي تقول ان واحد رغم كل
تهديدات والكلام في الهواء ان كان في خط
احمر واضح ان احنا مش هنحارب
ما فيش حرب الامريكان ومش هيحارب ليه لان
هو راجل عنده اخلاق يعني ولكن يقول لك ده
فلوس وانا راجل اعمال وعاوز احسب انا هكسب
كم واخسر كم طيب ده الاقتصاد الامريكي مش
هيخسر انما شركات السلاح اللي هي واحده من
اكبر اللوبيات في الولايات المتحده واللي
حققت فيه 2022 بس بسبب حرب اوكرانيا اول
خمس شركات فيها لسه التقرير طالع من شعر
ولا حاجه 195 مليار دولار اكبر خمس شركات
مش مش كل الشركات يعني فانت بتتكلم على
رقم مهول يعني لو امريكا بتقول لي
اوكرانيا انا اديتكم 160 مليار دولار هي
شركتها حققت 195 مليار معظمها بسبب حرب
اوكرانيا
لما
يتحدى مثلا لوبيات كتيره هو الراجل
عنده شك في الحكومه
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه طبعا هو دخل في
مشاكل
بس الشركات
الشركات
التسليح راجل عنده دخل في مشاكل مع
الاعلام داخل اللي هي الوسائل التقليديه
داخل في مشاكل مع عمالقه التكنولوجيا فهو
داخل في مشاكل مع الكثيرين يعني
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد ما المقصود
بالتهديدات الانتقاليه
زينب انا ما اعرفش قصدك في انهي سياق يعني
لو توضحي لي السياق ممكن اساعد يا زينب
لماذا فشلت الدول العربيه في بناء
الاقتصادات المتطوره قصه طويله يا جرش لكن
انا هنعمل حلقه ان شاء الله كنت لسه بتكلم
عنها صديقنا الدكتور مدحت نافع نتكلموا
اصدقاء اخرين والله هنتكلم لماذا فشلت
الدول العربيه في ان تكون دول صناعيه
متطوره حاضر يا اخونا جرش
متى ستضرب اسرائيل ايران
ستضرب اسرائيل ايران اجابنا باحدى حلقات
اعجابنا
هل
نور الدين او نور الدين اسف السلام عليكم
استاذ جبيل هل صحيح ان هناك بعض الصناعات
المحرمه على الدول العربيه والاسلاميه ام
ان الامر راجع الى نقص وغياب كفاءات لا هو
في صناعات محرمه ليست على الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه ولكن صناعات محرمه على كل
الدول اللي هي ما عندهاش هذه التكنولوجيات
يعني عشان ما اكونش كلام يلخبط يعني مثلا
صناعه الصواريخ او صناعه القنبله النوويه
لا يحدث ان في دوله بتهدي دوله القنبله
النوويه انت مش دوله عربيه ولا اسلاميه
لكن هو لن يعطيك مثلا لن يعطيها مثلا
لم يعطيها لدوله اوروبيه زي السويد او
فنلندا او كذا لا دي حاجات لا تلقى لاحد
اصلا
فالمساله مش مرتبطه بالعالم العربي
والاسلام لا تعطل الدول الافريقيه لا
تعطيل الدول الاسلاميه لا تعطي لامريكا
اللاتينيه لانه هذه التكنولوجيات الحساسه
الدول اللي تمكنت من انجازها تمكنت لا
تريد او يعني تريد ان تحتكر هذه
التكنولوجيات
ده حساسيتها الشديده ولا يمكن ان هي
تباعها في السوق زي ما بتبيع مثلا
الموبايلات في تكنولوجيات اقل حساسيه ولكن
دي براءه ملكيه فكريه انا بخترع سالفون او
تليفون وده بيعيد علي بحاجات كتيره فانا
ما بديش براءه يعني ما بنقلش التكنولوجيه
ديت بسهوله برضو لاي دوله لا عربيه ولا
اسلاميه ولا مسيحيه ولا بوتيه يعني فرد
على حضرتك نعم هناك تكنولوجيات ممنوعه
عليك والدول تحاربك الدول اللي بتملكها
بتحاربك مش لانك انت عربي ولا انك اسلامي
ولكن لانك مش هما يعني انت لست هم
اذا كان في ذهنك اسرائيل استبعد اسرائيل
اسرائيل دي قصه لوحدها استثناء من
الاستثناء
رايك بكتاب قص الحق ومؤلفه دكتور جميل
اكبر لا اعلم الكتاب
دكتور جميل اكبر قص الحق فانا كويس انت
لفت نظر الحاجه ما اعرفهاش وما اكثر ما لا
اعلم يعني وبالتالي لا استطيع
ان ابدي راي فيما لا اعلمه
نرايا حضرتك في فلسفه دكتور عبد الوهاب
المثيري من حيث رؤيته للعلمانيه والله
دكتور
عبد الوهاب المسيري رحمه الله اولا هو
اسمه بيخوف اصلا لانه ده كان راجل عنده
عقليه كبيره جدا في اي حاجه بتيجي من
نوعيه عبد الوهاب المسيري حتى لو بان
الراي من متهافت الى انه هو مخيف لانه
بتضطر انت تدقق فيما يقول عده مرات ده من
ناحيه اما وقد قلت ذلك فهو مراحل كثيره
لكن المرحله الاخيره انه كان لي راي سيء
جدا في العلمانيه لكن المشكله في تعريف
العلمانيه هو عنده تعريف فلسفي كاسح
لمفهوم العلمانيه انكار الله انكار
الاخلاق يعني حاجات كثيره كده انما
العلمانيه اللي احنا بنتكلم عليها هي
العلمانيه اللي اعتقد لو كان رحمه الله
موجودا
ما اعتقدش انك انت هتبقى نقطه خلاف
العلماريه بتتكلم على علمانيه الدوله ان
الدوله ما يكونش عندها دين بمعنى لا تتبنى
دينا معينا واذا تبنى الدين معين لان ده
راي الناس هي بتحترم كل الاديان وكل
العقائد واللي عاوز يصلي في الجامعه اهلا
وسهلا واللي عاوز يصلي في الكنيسه اهلا
وسهلا واللي مش عاوز يصلي خالص هذا شانه
اللي هي الفكره اللي قامت عليها فكره
الدوله الحديثه اللي ما اعتقدش انه لا
الدكتور عبد الوهاب المسيري او غيره يكون
عنده تصور مختلف لاي لاي مجتمع حديث يقوم
بدون العلمانيه بهذا المعنى يعني
ما الفائده من صرف تريليون دولار لبداء
ناطحات سحاب
بتتكلم على مين يا اسلام بقى الاقامه
دولار مش عارف والله ما اعرف فعلا قصدك
مين جعفر اهلا بك يا جعفر هل النظام
السياسي في المغرب جدا انت في حاجه محذوفه
استاذ سعد ما احنا مش انت كاتب كده بالظبط
في مصر ما فيش تمييز مع المسيحيين اعتقد
انا نادرا لماذا
اعتقد انا
ما بناخدش بالنا بيفكر ده مسيحي له
اه يعني انا فهمت الرساله بس يمكن في بعض
الكلام يعني الكلام يمكن بعض الكلام محذوف
تقول رنا راشد ان ما فيش فرق ما فيش تمييز
الاثنين مضطهدين مسلمين والمسيحيين ومش كل
الناس بياخدوا بالهم ده مسلم ولا مسيحي يا
رنا الاجابه بتختلف على الوسط الاجتماعي
اللي انت بتتكلمي عليه يعني في وسط
اجتماعي مصر مش مش وسط اجتماعي واحد
اجتماعيه هي بتربي اولادها على الطريق
اللي انت بتقولي عليها ده ممكن عائله
واحده
يعني انا اذكر ان اولادي اول مره ينتبهوا
للفروق ديت لما حصلت انا اولادي دلوقتي سن
19 ل 21 يعني انما كان اول مره ينتبهوا
وهم كانوا في مدرسه فيها اعداد كبيره جدا
من المسيحيين زمايلهم فدول معاهم في
المدرسه ومعهم في النادي بيقول البيت هنا
فما كانوش ينتبهوا قوي وما يعرفوش لغايه
سن مش صغير يعني في ابتدائي ما يعرفوش
القصه دي عارفين انه في درس اسمه درس
مسيحي ودرس المسلمين بس مش منتبهين
المساله مش فيها تزن قوي انما بدا ينتبهوا
لما حصلت عمليات ويعني نسفت كنائس فبدا
يطرح السؤال يعني انما في اوساط اجتماعيه
اخرى
الاوساط دي بتعلم الناس بوضوح الفرق بين
هذا الدين وذاك الدين وهوسو انك اعلى
وافضل الى اخره كل المجتمعات ليس قاصرا
على المسلمين لانه كمان هناك مسيحيين
متطرفين
وفي كل الاديان حتى في المجتمعات
العلمانيه والمجتمعات المتطوره والتعصب
موجود وبعض العلمانيين اكثر تطرفا من
المتدينين
التطرف معناها
صاحب الفكره نفسه يعني مش عاوز اقول كلمه
مش مناسبه يعني ولكن بتكون قدراته الذهنيه
اقل شويه من الشخص المتسامح لانه هو تصلب
حوالين فكره وبيعتقد ان هو صاحب الحق
المطلق زي ما بيكون الدكتور مراد وهبه
يعني الله يدي له طوله العمر فدي دايما في
كل مجتمع لانه عدد الناس اللي هم عندهم اي
كيو عالي وذكاء وثقافه دول بطبيعتهم لازم
يكون اعدادهم قليلين
السلام عليكم نريد منك برنامج تتحدث فيه
عن السياسه الخارجيه العمانيه
حاضر
سويسرا العرب
سلطنه عمان
السلام عليكم انا عايش في امريكا
بالاقتصادي في زياده يقولون ان السبب هو
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا هل هذا صحيح لا
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا واحد من هذه
الاسباب انما ليست كل هذه الاسباب
الحقيقه احنا قلنا موجات لكن السبب
الرئيسي اللي مخلي التدخل عارف الولايات
المتحده هو الاسراف في طباعه النقود كحل
لكل المشاكل سنه 29 ضرب الكساد الكبير
الولايات المتحده
وهذه قصه يطول شرحها ادرك الاقتصاديون بعد
دراسات طويله انه كان حل الكساد الكبير
انه الدوله كانت تطبع مزيد من الدولارات
لاحد النظريات يعني
يبدو انه الاقتصاديين الامريكان اوفرلار
اوفرلار
وتعلموا الدرس باكثر مما ينبغي فكل ما
بتقولهم مشكله تقريبا يعني علاجها اطبع
نقود
وعليه فلما انت
الاقتصاد علم والعلم بيقول ان التضخم
بينتج من
اموال كثيره تطارد بضائع قليله
علشان التضخم ما يكونش موجود لازم تتاكد
انه ما فيش كميات نقود كبيره دخلت السوق
وبالتالي خلق الطلب كثير على يعني بضائع
قليله الانتاج ما بيقدرش يزيد باضطراب لكن
الاموال تقدر تاخد قرار طباعه فتنبع او
تعرض فلوس يعني مش لازم تكون طباعه بشكل
ما عنده يعني قرر انه يزود المعروض من
الفلوس عنده فلوس اوريدي وبيخفض عليه
الفايده فالفلوس بتتسرب من البنوك الى
الناس بسهوله في ايديهم كل ده حصل على
مدار العشرين سنه اللي فاتت من 2008 الى
الان في كم فلوس كثيره ما يتحقق الان هي
النظريه اللي موجوده في الكتب اموال كثيره
تطارد بضائع قليله ثم جاءت حرب
فيروس كورونا ثم حرب
روسيا واوكرانيا
والان ما يفعله الفيدرالي الامريكي هو
محاوله امتصاص هذه السيوله
مضت ماذا تعلم
ماذا تعلم العالم من ازاحه صدام حسين هو
الواضح ان العيب مش في الكتابه الواضح
العيب في عيني انا انتوا كاتبين صح وانا
اللي مش عارفه اقرا هل من الممكن ان يتكرر
السيناريو مع الاسد
هو الاسد مش صدام حسين يعني اولا سوريا
ليست العراق العراق جائزه كبرى بحكم
ثرواتها الكبيره هذا اولا ثانيا صدام حسين
كان احيانا رحمه الله عليه رحمه للجميع
كان يتصرف احيانا لايك
راي حضرتك في مصر الثلاث سنوات القادمه هل
في انهيار ازدهار استبعد فكره الانهيار
واستبعد فكره الازدهار ولكن اميل واتمنى
طبعا يكون في اصدار اميل الى انه سوف يتم
تجاوز العاصفه لانه ما فيش دوله في
المنطقه ولا في العالم ممكن يعني تفكر في
ان هذا الكابوس قد يتحقق يعني انه مصر
تخرج من هذه الازمه كما خرجت من ازمات
اخرى لكن هنحتاج كتير قوي علشان يحصل هذا
نتعلم بقى الدرس الحقيقي ليه الازمه دي
حصلت وليه ازمات تانيه كتيره هنحتاج كتير
جدا جدا وهنحتاج قرارات مؤلمه وهنحتاج
موصى راحه بالحقائق واول هذه الحقيقه ليه
اقتصاد مصر دايما ماذون
والحقائق معروفه للكل يعني ما هياش حاجه
جديده
انما ردا على سؤالك لا انهيار ولا ازدهار
لا سؤال لدي وانما تعليق صغير اتمنى ان
يتم استخدام لفظ تطبيعي الا مع اسرائيل
واستخدام اعاده العلاقات واي وصف لما يحدث
بين السعوديه وايران او غيرها شكرا جزيلا
يا اسيل اذا كان الاسم سليم ولكن انا عاوز
اقول لحضرتك انه في النهايه الصحفيين
احيانا بيكونوا مضطرين اضطرارا الى
الكلمات ممكن ده في بحث علمي ممكن يكون في
ندوه انما احيانا بتكون الكلمه اللي شعرت
بين الناس بتستخدم حتى ولو كانت خاطئه
يعني
انا بحترم وجهه نظرك يعني انا فاهم وجهه
نظرك صحيح
عثمان العلاقات المغربيه الجزائريه هل
يمكن ان ينجر البلدان لحرب بينهما ولماذا
تدعم مصر جبهه البوليساريو مع انها تسعى
لانفصال عن بلد عربي اسلامي
هو ده بقى يعني انا انا جالي كميه بتعامل
حلقه على النيجر جات لي كم من التعليقات
بعض الاصدقاء المغاربه زعلانين من خريطه
حاضر
على الخريطه يا اصدقاء يجب ان تعلموا
اصدقائنا المغرب كل الاحترام لرايكم في ان
الصحراء مغربيه انا والله هذا الموضوع
واعتقد انا في تقديري ان هم لو توصلوا الى
الاقامه بلان خطه اللي هم بيعلنونها من
2007 وبالمناسبه ده كان يعني
[موسيقى]
بمفاوضات كبيره كمان مع حلفاء امريكا
وفرنسا يعني انه تبقى الصحراء او تتحول
الى اقليم برضا كل الناس يكون احسن للكل
ده راي يعني لانه الحل التاني ما هواش
قائم لكن انا رايي انا ولا حاجه خالص انا
صحفي قاعد على كرسي
اللي حاصل ان الامم المتحده الاتحاد
الافريقي محكمه العدل الدوليه
المحاكم الاوروبيه المحكمه الدستوريه
الاوروبيه الكبيره يعني المحكمه العليا
الاوروبيه كل دول بيقولوا ان هذه الصحراء
هي ليست ملكا للمغرب
وان وجود المغرب عليه احتلال ده مش رايي
سيد ومش معناه ان انا بايده وقال عايز
استفز
انا بقول يعني هذا هو الموقف لانه في
مشكله في القصه دي المغرب بتقول مهما قال
العالم
المغرب في صحراءه والصحراء في مغربه بكل
سرور اهلا وسهلا هي الطريقه استراتيجيه
بما ان المجتمع الدولي مت يعني
كلهم هذا الموقف لاسباب بتول شرحها يعني
حتى لو هم من اصدقائي المغرب زي فرنسا زي
اسبانيا زي دول كثيره زي كل الدول بما
فيها اداره بايدن رغم البلد في ايام ترامب
اعترف بالسياده لكن بايدن جنب هذا
الاعتراف برضو الاسباب اللي طول شرحهم
فايه الحاصل
المغرب بيتبع سياسه ان هي تقوم على
الاتفاقات الثنائيه ان انا امارس كل
الضغوط والاقراءات على اصدقائي الاقنعهم
بهذا الامر بس يعني انت بتقول مصر على انا
ما اعرفش انه مصر البوليساريو ولا حاجه
مصر موقفها زي دول كتيره بتقول انه بتحاول
طب الجزائر والمغرب وده موقف معظم دول
العالم لكنها لا تعترفوا بسياده المغرب
لان دي لها اشكاليه قانونيه اذا فعلوا ذلك
يترتب عليها ان دول اخرى تقول والله انا
على ارض الواقع انا اضع يدي على هذه
المنطقه واريدها الحل المثالي للقضيه ديت
وطبعا هيعملوا مشكله مع الجزائريين اعملوا
مشكله مع بعض دول افريقيا انما المشكله
الاكبر هي في كسر قاعده قانونيه موجوده في
هذه المؤسسات
ارجو ان يكون الفكره واضحه يعني
الصوت مش احسن حاجه اعمل صوت احسن حاجه
كويس طب يا شباب لو حد له راي تاني لو
بصيت انت في التعليقات الاخيره هيرد عليك
فورا لكن انا يسعد مساك استاذ جبيل اهلا
وسهلا جعفر السلام عليكم ما المقصود
بالتهديدات الانتقاليه في نظام الدولي او
ممكن كده يا زينب اوضح شويه لو كنت انا
فاهم ان في مراحل انتقاليه وفي المراحل
الانتقاليه بيكون في نظام قائم بدا يضعه
وفي نظام جديد بيتشكل وبالتالي بيكون في
فوضى زي الفوضى اللي احنا عايشينها دي ولو
انت يا زمن بتحبي شرح كامل انا عامل حلقه
بعنوان كيف نفهم الفوضى في العالم بكلمه
واحده اللي هي كلمه يعني النظام الانتقالي
او الفتره الانتقاليه وعاملها تاني في
حلقه كانت عباره عن محاضره في دوله يعني
او في في البحرين بتكلم فيها على كيف نفهم
ما يجري في العالم اين على الفكره ديت
فكره المخاطر اللي بتيجي نتيجه المرحله
الانتقاليه بالنظامين
يعني لو كتبت كلمه الفوضى وماذا يجري في
العالم ان شاء الله هيظهر لك على القناه
شنوده ازاي يتم تنقيح التشريعات في
الوزارات المختلفه للاصلاح للاصلاح
الاداري وليه
اليه ذلك وجد وجدوله الزمني يا اخونا ده
كان مشروع هو بيتكلم على اعتقد بتتكلم على
مصر
ومنطبق على مصر ينطبق على دوله اخرى ايه
مشكله احد مشاكل مصر اللي هي معلومه للبعض
ومسكوت عنها انه انت النهارده لو عندك
عاوز تعمل
عاوز تاخد تصريح بنا انت عاوز تعمل اي
حاجه فانت بتروح بورقه للموظفين بتعدي
الاول على 140 موظف الموظف ده بيفتح
القوانين اللي عنده واحد يقول لك اه واحد
ممكن يقول لك لا الفكره مش بس ان هو فاسد
او كسول او عدم الكفاءه دي حاجات مشتركه
في كل البني ادمين او ممكن وارد ولكن في
سبب تاني اعمق من كده انه في كم تشريعات
متراكم بعضه موجود من
من ايام محمد علي
ما تغيرش وبيكون موجود وبيجي تشريع جديد
مش بيحل محل التشريع القديم ولكن بيبقى
يعني بيقف الى جواره القصه ديت طرحت كتير
وظهرت مبادره من حوالي عشره 12 سنه اسمها
اراده وكان الهدف من هذه المبادره من
مجموعه من المسؤولين السابقين والنخب انه
يتم تنقيه التشريعات المصريه بحيث انه يتم
حذف طبعا الحذف ده مش مش بيشطب عليه
بالالم ولكن بيضع عليه كده وبعدين يعرض
على مجلس الشعب وتمشي في الاجراءات وقطعوا
شوطا ولكن اجهضت تبعا لاسباب سياسيه كامله
واسباب مصالح لان تعدد التشريعات مش لانه
الناس مش واخده بالها التعدد جزء من
الفساد تعدد التشريعات جزء من عدم اراده
الدوله من تضارب المصالح يعني الاصل في
التشريع انه
في حاجه حاجه يعني هناك سبب يدعو الى
تشريع قانون ان انا عاوز مثلا مثلا يعني
اسم قاعده قانونيه تقول بانه الشرطه لها
حق القبض على الناس مثلا او انه النيابه
الاداريه او اي حاجه يعني
او ان القوات المسلحه من حقها ان هي تقوم
بعمليه الضبطيه القضائيه انا بدي كمثال
اللي بيحصل ان المفروض يكون فيه سبب وجه
لده ثم يعرض على مجلس الشعب ثم يروحوا
للمرحله كذا ثم يطبق اللي حاصل من سنين
طويله من حبلي سبعين سنه والدكتور الاستاذ
الشهير وبالمناسبه كان بيكلمني النهارده
مشكوره ربنا يخليه دكتور علي الغريب انا
كنت ناشر معي حوار اكتب كده سيد جبيل علي
الغدير دكتور علي الغتيد
الفقيه القانون المشهور في حوار حوالي
2500 كلمه بياثر فيها هذه المشكله انه من
ايام من ايام ثوره 52 اتعاكست المساله
القرار بيجي من السياسي للتشريع اعمل
القانون ده
فما بيمرش بالمراحل دي النتيجه هو ليه
عاوز يعمل القانون ده ومعتقد ان ده هيمشي
الامور بسرعه الى يومنا هذا هذا يتم يعني
السياسي يعطي امرا بحكم سيطرته على
المجالس التشريعيه وعلى الجهات المعنيه
فبيتم اقرار قوانين لم تتم دراستها
والنتيجه ان احنا عندنا فوضى
انت بتقول المدى الزمني المدى الزمني ده
اخونا شنوده لما يكون هناك اراده بدات
اصلا لكن حتى الان المساله ديت ما هياش
مطروحه يعني السلام عليكم هل لديك معلومات
عن الوضع في سوريا
الامريكيه في شرقيه والفعل لا يوجد بديل
لبشار الاسد من وجهه نظر امريكا حاليا
معلومات عن الوضع في سوريا والتجهيزات
الامريكيه في شرقها يعني
مش قادر افهم انت بتشير اليه تحديدا
الولايات المتحده موجوده في شرق وشمال
سوريا بقوته الموجودين احنا بنتكلم على
اظن حوالي 900 جندي على ما اذكر وبنتكلم
بقى حلفائهم اللي هم قوات قصد
موجودين مقرهم في قاعده التنف هو قواعد
اقل حجما هم موجودون بالدرجه الاولى يعني
الموقف وبدهم موجود علشان يقول والله انا
علشان اضرب الجامعات المتطرفه الكلام ده
كان وجيه وما زال فيه بعض الوجه بس ليس هو
السبب الرئيسي في سبب ثاني اعلنوا نحن
موجودون في سوريا بسياساتنا او عسكريين
علشان نراقب الايرانيين ونراقب الروس
وندعم الاسرائيليين يعني هذا هو الاهداف
اللي موجوده
هل لا يوجد لبشار
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه هو واضح انه له
يعني قوه تدعمه وله قوه لا تعارضه بشده
يعني فيبقى هو لا يوجد له بديل حتى الان
ما رايك في هجره المصريه العيش في المغرب
المغرب بلد جميل ربنا يوفقهم ما هو مستقبل
اوكرانيا يعني لن يكون له
يعني المراه اوكرانيا بلد
تم تحطيمه رغم الدعم الامريكي له
في سيناريوهات كثيره طبعا ولكن في كل
الاحوال هو هيخرج من هذه الحرب
بخسائر اكبر بكثير جدا جدا للاسف يعني مما
لو كان لم يستمع الى كلمات التشجيع
الغربيه له
فطيمه
تحياتي السيد افضل قناه اشكرك
ما هي اليات التطبيق الثقافي والشعبي بين
الدول العربيه واسرائيل ومن يمول
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
متخصص في العلوم الاجتماعيه واتابعك
واشجعك ربنا يخليك يا مروان على شاكر جدا
لك جدا جدا كثر الف خيرك
لكن هي كانت رسالتك الطيبه تكفي جدا
اوكي شكرا كثر خيرك الصوت صعب جدا جدا جدا
هو نفس يا عمرو الصوت كويس
طيب في امكانيه العلاجه
اتكلم طيب
نصف ثانيه يا شباب
قادره على دخول منظمه بريكس بمؤهلاتها
الحاليه وهل سيكون في ذلك فائده لها
الجزائر عندها الامكانيات انها تدخل لكن
المنافسه كبيره
وصوت كده كويس حد رد عمرو بقى هتيجي في
التعليقات الاخيره عشان بس ما الاسئله ما
اسيبهاش
هي بلد عنده ينطبق عليه الشروط الاوليه
انها بلد محوري في في منطقه
عنده غاز او عنده ثروات يعني بلد متماسك
يعني انما المنافسه كبيره لان المنافسه مع
السعوديه واندونيسيا
ومصر والامارات المنافسه كبيره
وبعدين في الدول داخل المجموعه مش عاوزه
اعضاء الجدد البرازيل والهند المتحفظين
البرازيل مش عاوزه ببساطه يعني يقول لك
والله انا انا كمبصوط احنا قاعدين انا
واحد قاعده مع خمس دول مع اربع دول غيري
اذا دخلت خمسه سته عشره 12 انا مش هستفيد
صوتي هيبقى كاني قاعد في الامم المتحده
يعني
الهند لها موقف لها قصه عجيبه غريبه ولكن
هي حاسه ان ده هيخدم الصين اللي هي خصمتها
يعني خصموها
فربا على سؤالك
يعني المساله مش يعني مش مقطوع بها هم
يجتمعوا فيه اغسطس وقبل اغسطس في عشرين
اغسطس اظن يعني في اخر هذا الشهر وقبليه
ان شاء الله يكون عندنا حلقه عن التفاصيل
باذن الله فيما يخص الشان المغربي الى اين
ستقول العلاقات الجزائريه المغربيه هل
هناك امل لعوده العلاقات هناك امل عوده
العلاقات ولكن عوده العلاقات لا يعني اي
شيء معناها ان التوتر قل نسبيا كانت
العلاقات سيئه والسفراء موجودين صعب جدا
في علاقات بتفضل دايما فيها حساسيات مزمنه
يمكن ان تتحسن قليلا تهدا ولكن التعاقدات
اللي موجوده بين المغرب والجزائر تناقضات
الجوهريه لانها قائمه على معادله صفريه ما
ينفعك يضرني وما يضرك ينفعني وهي مش حاجه
عجيبه ولا غريبه في العلاقات الدوليه بص
لحاله اليونان وتركيا
بص لحاله مثلا الهند والصين بص لحاله
اليابان
وبعض جيرانها
شوف حاله روسيا وائل الولايات المتحده
وهكذا يعني
هل اقتربت نهايه السيسي ما عنديش تعليق يا
اخوانا سعد هو عنده انتخابات يدخل فيها
والانتخابات تحدد هذا ما اعرفش يعني ايه
اقتربت نهايه السيسي حسب خبرتك هل الجزائر
قادره على دخول رجبنا السلام عليكم لماذا
موريتانيا رغم كميه الذهب والحديد
واكتشافات الغزل من الثروات الطبيعيه ديت
مرتبطه بالفقر وفي حاجه اسمها لعنه
الموارد الطبيعيه الموارد الطبيعيه ديت ده
النظريه في الاقتصاد يعني انما يعني لان
ده امر يطول شرحه
مش طول قوي يعني في دول
هي دول فقيره بتعتمد على انها بتبيع ماده
خام بس اولا الماده الخام دي بتقيم اودها
يا دوبك الناس تاكل وتشرب فده ما بيشجعهاش
قوي انها تكافح لان هي ما عندهاش حاجه
وعاوزه تبقى حاجه زي زي مثلا يعني ظروف
اليابان ده من ناحيه لكن من ناحيه تانيه
ان بيخليها مطمع للدول الكبيره اللي بتبقى
معنيه بان هي تنهبها مش ان هي تطورها
الحاجه الثالثه انه دي بتتباع سلعه خام
يعني بيباع السلعه خام هي سلع حيويه مهمه
لكن سعرها خام ولا حاجه انت لما بتبيع
برميل البترول بتبيعه مثلا ب 100 دولار
انما لما بتبيعه
منتجات متطوره بيكون
يعني اضعاف هذا الرقم
هل يوجد شركات بترول بترول الاسرائيليه في
مصر
ولو موجود مش هتبقى حاجه غريبه لان المعلن
انه اسرائيل انا ما اعرفش شركه اسرائيليه
بتيجي وهم برضو يعني عاده بيتاخدوا اسماء
اخرى نتيجه انه لاسباب امنيه حتى شركه
العال اللي بتطير من القاهره لتل ابيب هي
جدول الرحلات مش مدرك كده على المطار لانه
يبدو ان هذا بيخلي الناس تتقدم من القصه
والاسباب الامنيه انما اكيد هيكون في
موجود لكن انا ما اعرفش انا بقول ليه اكيد
لانه العلاقات المصريه الاسرائيليه
بينظمها قانون ومصر بتستورد
الغاز الاسرائيلي بعد ان كانت تصدره علشان
تسيلوا وتبيعه ففي علاقات
الصوت اتحسن عمرو
لسه شويه فيه مشكله يعني
ممكن يكون ده كده
طيب احنا كان عندنا المشكله دي ظهرت من
يومين يبدو ان في لكن لو في حاجه من فضلكم
ردوا علي
هل مصر ستدخل البريكس مصر بدوله مقدمه ضمن
دول كثيره جدا لدخول البريكس تدخل املاه
برضه حد تاني الصوت سيء جدا
طب انا هبص على التعليقات الاخيره كده
ده اللي فوق
لحظه يا شباب انا هرجع عشان اتاكد من
التعليقات وارجع تاني
مش عارف ارجع تاني
الصوت
مخنوق ده عامل زي اللي انا كنت بقول لك
عليه
ان شاء الله نراعيها المره القادمه
ده هو حد احد التعليقات يعني
حد بيقول الصوت تمام
طيب
انا اسف انا رجعت للاول تاني في حد بيقول
لي لا اعرف من اين اتيت بان الامم المتحده
ومحكمه العدل الدوليه تعتبر ان الصحراء
ليست مغربيه والمغرب كان محتل اعتقد انك
متاثر بالبروباندا الجزائريه يا اخي عيب
ان انت تقول لي انا متاثر الجزائريه انا
صحفي بقى لي 30 سنه اولا انا ليه علاقه لا
لمصلحه لا مع المغرب ولا الجزائر بالعكس
ده انا انا بغض النظر انا مش عاوز ادخل في
هذا ما اقول انا ما بقولش كلام منقول من
قصاصات جرائد انا بقول كلام له مصادر ومش
محتاجه مصادر لان دي حقائق يعني
لكل الساسه والمثقفين المغاربه وكلامي انا
اصلا لا يحمل لا تجريح للمغاربه ولا مدح
في غيرهم لكن بقوله لك
لا يا اخونا بلال ما قلت لك دقيق تقدر انت
لو انت ابحث باللغه الفرنسيه او باللغه
الانجليزيه بلاش مصادر عربيه ولو ان في
بعض المصادر العربيه سوف تجد كل معلومه
قلتها لك عن محكمه من اول سنه 1975 وحكم
محكمه العدل الدوليه
الذي لم يجد منه وبالمناسبه كان ده بناء
على طلب المغرب هتجد ان منطقه الصحراء
مكتوبه في
[موسيقى]
الجبرنتي مناطق لا تتمتع بالحكم الذاتي هي
بتتصدر هذه المناطق في الامم المتحده
نفس الكلام لكن ردا على كلامك يعني راجع
معلوماتك يا اخواننا بلال والدي الاستاذ
شحات عبد العال حي يحيى حضرتك
وليد الاستاذ شحاته عبد العال يحيى
وليد الاستاذ شحاته عبد العالي حي حضرتك
بيستفيد من شرحك المبسط شكرا جزيلا يا عبد
الرحمن وشكرا جدا
لوالدك الاستاذ شحات عبد اتشرف بمتابعتكم
وبلال انا مش قصدي ان انا ازعلك بس يعني
يعني
اللي انا قلته لك صحيح يعني لا مراه فيك
وانت اسال من تثق فيه اكتر مني هيقول لك
هذا الكلام وكرر الشكر للاستاذ شحاته
المغرب مكتوره من صحراءه في حلقاتك
السابقه كان مقصودا ام مجرد سهوا لا
مقصودا ولا سهوا انا اذا تدخلت هذه
الخرائط
انا ارجو من الاخوه المغاربه انهم ما
يخلوش المساله تاخدنا في هذه القصه ده
موضوع يعني انا ما عنديش موقف من القصه
ربنا يوفق المغاربه في الصحراء وانا بتكلم
اذا انا دي خريطه اللي موجوده اللي هي
بتقول عليها الاتحاد الافريقي ال 54 دوله
دي اللي بتقول عليها الامم المتحده
مش انا اللي عاوزها لكن اذا انا تدخلت
يبقى انا بتبنى وجهه نظر المغرب بدون سبب
يعني انا اللي عاوز اتبنى وجهه نظر المغرب
ولا وجهه نظر الصحراويين ولا وجهه نظر
الجزائريين محكمه العدل الدوليه انا مقدر
ان لو حد بيسمع الكلام ده لاول مره يبقى
متوتر بس معلش
يعني كويس انك انت تسمع وجهات نظر مختلفه
وانا عرضت وجهه نظري باكبر قدر ممكن من
الوقت وان شاء الله نخصص لها حلقه تانيه
لان ممكن يكونوا اخرين
مهتمين انه يسمعوا قضايا اخرى محكمه العدل
الدوليه لم تقل ما قلت عن الصحراء وبيض لم
يجمد من اين تاتي بهذا الكلام لا الكلام
اللي انا بقوله لحضرتك سليم انه فيما
يتعلق بمحكمه العدل الدوليه الكلام ده من
عام 1975 ونص المحكمه موجود وتقدر ترجع له
بل وهخصصلك حلقه واكتب لك فيه المصدر
مكتوب فيما يتعلق باداره بايدن كانت
الخطوه المفروض تؤخذ في الوقت اللاحق هو
انه
ليا بيض المقراتش انه يغضب المغاربه لكن
في نفس الوقت عنده مشكله ومتحفظ على
القرار ومتاثر
بالديمقراطيين الدبلوماسيين اللي كانوا
بيعارضوا هذه الفكره ولا يريد ان يغضب
الجزائريين ولا يريد ان هو يتورط في هذا
الموضوع
وبالتالي هو قرر انه لا ينقص او لا يعود
فيما قاله بيضا
وفي نفس الوقت ما قاله ترامبو وما يطورش
العلاقات زي ما عمل في قرارات اخرى كثيره
اخذها ترامب منها مثلا ترامبال انه
ثواني يا شباب
ما اتكلمش عنها
تمام
السيد قبيل لو سمحت لبنان الى اين
وارتباطه بسوريا تاريخيا سياسيا مصريا
مروان من لبنان
لبنان الى اين لبنان في وضع بلغ السوق
لبنان سوف يعني اعلن عمليا انه متعثر عن
سداد ديونه
ما عندوش حكومه تقريبا
يعني الاقتصاديا ولا سياسيا
كنت امل يعني انه
هدوء التوتر نسبيا بين السعوديه
وايران انه دي ينعكس اجابه على لبنان زي
ما تحسن قليلا بس برضو التوتر منخفضش
بالشكل اللي هو يحتاج وقت
والاسرائيليين والامريكان مش عاوزين يدوا
الفرصه ديت وبيحاولوا انه يلهبوا العلاقات
السعوديه الايرانيه مره اخرى نامل نامل
انه
الهدوء يحصل الاول ما بين الخليجيين
والايرانيين ثم ينعكس على لبنان لان ملهاش
امل تاني يعني
السلام عليكم مهضور الجزائر في النيجر زي
ما فيش دور للجزائر اولا هي موقفها
المعلنه مش عاوزه اي تدخل عسكري بس لازم
يكون لها راي لان دي عندها يعني دي دوله
جوار مباشره النيجر وبالتالي اي فوضى
هتحصل في النيجر هتنعكس على الجزائر
ولانها دوله جوار فده قالقها جدا انه اذا
حصلت حرب هناك هتبقى في موجات هجره وموجات
الهجره هتغرقها املا في الوصول اليها او
الى اوروبا
بليز
يعني
مش متاكد ان ممكن استضيف حد بقى يتكلم عن
فما لازم
في حاجه تانيه يا عمرو
اوكي
احاول ايه يا صديقي لماذا الشعب السعودي
غير منزعج من الانفتاح وعلى العكس متقبل
ان ده طبيعه الامور يعني في شعب يكون في
سنه 2021 وتلاته وعشرين يكون من الطبيعي
انه لسه بيناقشوا انه السيده تقود سياره
ولا لا يكون في حفلات ولا لا يكون ان انا
امشي في الشارع فاصلي او اجبر على الصلاه
ما دي كانت حاجات كان يجب ان يتم تغيير
المساله فيها من زمان يعني فالانفتاح
بالمعنى ده انا بشوفه ايجابي يعني ما
اعرفش انت كده شايفه سلبي
محكمه العدل الدوليه خلاص اجبت
اجابنا
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد ما تقديركم للوضع
الحالي في لبنان اجبت هل يمكن ان تصبح مصر
في يوم ما فيدراليه برلمانيه مثل المانيا
ليه من مصر مش محتاجه يعني كل شيء ممكن
ولكن فيدراليه ليه يعني تبقى يعني يبقى في
كل كل عده محافظات يعني عندها استقلال
ذاتي مش استقلال يعني عندها
يعني تبقى
عندها صلاحيات اعلى بكتير من الحكومه
المركزيه مش حاسه ان هي قضيه جوهريه عند
في مصر في المرحله الحاليه لكن كل شيء
ممكن
كانت حمله عامر موسى لما كان بيفكر للترشح
بتدرس الفكره ديت انما ما كانتش اولويه لا
على حملته ولا على حمله اي سياسي جاء في
السنوات الاخيره الثلاثين اربعين خمسين
سنه يعني اللي فاتت
هل فعلا الانتخابات الرئاسيه في فرنسا
وامريكا هي تفرز فعلا اختيارا ناخبين ام
ان هناك جهه ما تعين رؤساء هذه الدول لا
يا سعد ما فيش جهه ما بتجلس في الخفاء
وبتختار رئيس ولكن
الطبيعي جدا انه في اي دوله الاصوات ليست
واحده يعني لما يجي مثلا حد زي ايلون ماسك
راجل عنده مئات المليارات لما يكون عنده
رغبه في اختيار بايدن او مثلا ترامب وليس
بين صوته مش زي صوت الامريكي العادي ولا
صوت مليون امريكي عادي ده عنده قدره انه
يلقي يحط صوته هو صوته زي صوت اكس او واي
ولكن صوته ده هو بيسخر له كل امكانياته
وعلى ارض الواقع وبالتالي اللي بيحصل على
الارض الواقعين الانتخابات بتعبر عن
الاصوات الحقيقيه اللي موجوده لكن اذا
اراد النافذون امرا بيكون هم اكثر قد على
انفاذه وده طبيعي
[موسيقى]
اجت
ماذا يمكن ان يغيره اعاده انتخاب ترامبي
وغير الكثير يا صديقي زي ما جاء بيضا حبن
يلغي الكثير مما فعل ترامب ترامب سوف ياتي
ليغير الكثير مما فعله بايدن واولها اعاده
النظر في الحرب الدائره مع الروس
هل كليه زي علوم سياسيه تستحق الواحد
يدخلها ولا الافضل التعليم الذاتي لسياسي
للسياسه زي حضرتك سواء الكليه في مصر او
بره مصر مروان بيتوقف على هدفك اولا
الكليه لو انت هتدرس في كليه سياسه يعني
سواء سياسه او قصاد في الكليه سياسه او
اقتصاد او ما يعادلها في اي مكان هي
الكليه ما فيش شك لو دي رغبتك هتبقى افضل
من اللي انت تروح تدرس الزراعه وانت عاوز
تدرس سياسه او تدرس مثلا اعلام وانت عاوز
تدرس اقتصاد انما
فده من حيث المبدا بس انت عاوز تدرسهم
لايه هل ده ينفعك في كاريرك هل ده يتوقف
على اهدافك لكن او يعني بصفه عامه دراسه
الاقتصاد هو دراسه السياسه في الكليه
وحدها لا تكفي دي هتدي لك اساس بسيط ولازم
تبني عليه حتى لو عملت الماجستير ده بحث
بسيط بيخليك تحاول تحسن ادواتك في البحث
ولا حتى حملت الدكتوراه لو كان هو مش
هيطور احنا عندنا
عندنا يعني ايه في العالم العربي يعني انا
بقابل عدد كبير جدا من حمله الشهادات
العليا اللي هو الماجستير والدكتوراه عدد
منهم مميز وفاهم وبعضهم ابدا هو عمل بحث
وتوقف لانه ايه الدكتوراه يعني هي بحث
انا مش بقلل منها ده يا ريت يكون عندنا
اكبر عدد بس بقول وحدها لا تكفي شيء انت
لازم تطور امكانياتك ولازم تطلع ولازم
تعرف وهكذا يعني
محكمه العدلنا هذا السؤال ماشي اشكرك
احنا نقف على الدقيقه 11 بعد اذنكم
ممكن تقرا السؤال المثبت حاضر ايه السؤال
المثمر ممكن تقول لي عليه
مش عارف انا حاضر اهو انا احنا فاضل لنا
دقيقتين فانا هحاول علشان
يعني
نريد رايكم في حرب الخليج وايران القادمه
ان شاء الله ما يكونش في حرب يا صديقي ده
كينج برود ولكن احنا اتكلمنا على التوتر
كثيرا ما بين ما بين ايران والخليج
ومحاوله الدولتين محاوله ايران والدول
العربيه تفادي هذه الحرب اللي هتكون وبالا
الدول العربيه وعلى ايران لكن اسرائيل من
مصلحتها ان هذه الحرب تاخذها اطراف اخرى
وتتخلص فيها من من ايران او من الخطر
الايراني اسمي حسام ما هو توقعاتك
للانتخابات الامريكيه اخونا حسام ما زال
من المبكر جدا جدا جدا اي حد يعطيك توقعات
للانتخابات الامريكيه ببساطه لانه كل اولا
لسه فتره احنا بنتكلم على نوفمبر 202
مفاجات كثيره جدا قد تاتي لبيض مفاجات
كثيره قد تاتي داخل الحزب الجمهوري القضاء
قد يقضي على فرص ترامب في الترشح الاحوال
الصحيه او اداء بي يقضي على فرسه فمن
المبكر جدا جدا جدا فضل لنا سؤالين يعني
استاذنكم بالاسئله اللي هنتجاوزها هنرجع
نجاوبها مره اخرى
في المرات القادمه
في عندك اسئله الناس الحوا عليها وانا ما
خدتش بالي منها يا عمرو
عمرو بيقول لي كتير يعني
طيب انا احنا
طب ممكن يعني
ماذا سوف يحدث في السودان
احاول اخد حاجه من الاسئله الاخيره
ماذا عن الحشود العسكريه
طيب لحظه ماذا عن الحشود ده ارين ماذا عن
الحشود العسكريه الامريكيه في الخليج
وفطور العلاقات العربيه السوريه احنا كان
اول سؤال اجبناه هو الحشود العسكريه
الامريكيه
زي ما قلت لحضراتكم انا اجابته فعلا هو
قرار بتحركه الاعتبارات الانتخابيه رغبته
في انه يعمل انجاز كبير يتمثل في اقناع
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
بالتطبيع مع اسرائيل رغبته في انه يتقرب
الاسرائيليين ويؤكد دمه ليهم ولكن القرار
قد يؤدي الى النتائج وخيمه لانه هو بيراهن
على انه وجود هذه القوات
لن تغامر ايران بالرد لكن الاخطاء دايما
وارده
لماذا كل هذا التلهف على الانضمام للبريكس
اكثر من 23 دوله قدمت طلبا ده نور الدين
لا انا في حلقه ارجعيلها يا نوردين ليه كل
الدول بتتسابق لدخول البريكس فاستاذنك
ارجعيلها وانا كده كده هعمل حلقه ان شاء
الله اذا ربنا احيانا مع الاجتماع المقبل
ولكن في اجابه بسيطه لك يعني اجابه بسيطه
لغايه ما نتقابل مره تانيه هو انه ليس
لهذه الدول حقيقه الامر ما تخسره ولكن
لديها ما تكسبه ممكن ما تكسبش كثير ولكن
ان هي تتمتع بعلاقات
مميزه يبقى عندها وضع مميز في علاقتها
بعملاق زي الصين في انه يكون عندها علاقات
مميزه مع دول مؤثره زي الدول الاربعه
الاخرى اكيد هذا يغري
ما رايك بموضوع الاعتراف بالاجسام الطائره
الذي يجري حاليا في الكونجرس الامريكي
والله هذا موضوع يعني بعتقد انه مثير
للفضول ولكن هو مثير للفضول علم لا ينفع
وجهل لا يضر على الاقل لن يكون اولويه
ابدا ابدا يعني في اول مئه اولويه للعالم
العربي ولا الدول الاوروبيه لكن وبعدين
انا عاوز اعرف ليه بس الاجسام الطائره دي
ما بتجيش غير الامريكان يعني الصينيين لا
العرب كلهم لا امريكا اللاتينيه لا موضوع
شغل الامريكان لاي سبب يعني
السؤال لين الاخرانيين ماذا حصل للتحالف
العربي الاسرائيلي ضد ايران ومليشياته
تعثر لان الدول العربيه لا تريد ان تكون
جزءا من تحالف يؤدي يعني تحالفا يستعدي
ايران علنا وبالتالي يضعها في مواجهه مع
ايران لا تريدها
اجبني عن سؤالي انا اجابتك عن سؤالك فيما
يخص سوريا هل يوجد حرب هو يعني لا حرب بين
مين ومين هو الحرب اوريدي دائره ما انت
عندك البلد محتل الامريكان بيحتلوا
الاتراك بيحتلوه
وقوه اخرى موجوده موجوده على الورق ليست
محتله لان هي يعني بموافقه
الحكومه زي ايران وزي روسيا لكن حقيقه
الامر انه برضو جزء من اشكال الاحتلال
والاطراف دي بعضها المتصارع وفي جامعات
ارهابيه وفي جماعات خارج نطاق الدوله
يعني خارج سيطره الدوله فاذا كنت في شكل
من اشكال الانفلات تقصد حرب بقى بين الروس
ولا الامريكان يعني الامر صعب جدا لانه
هذه القوه ادركت قدرت تتعايش مع بعضها
لفتره طويله جدا وبتحكم قواعد الاشتباك
وعشان تحصل حرب لازم يكون
يعني في سبب قهري ولا يبدو لي ان في سبب
قهري يدعو الى هذه الحرب
السؤال الاخير ما هي وجهه نظرك تجاه الوضع
سوريا ماذا اجبت اجبت طيب السؤال الاخير
يا عم سيد جبيل ما اثر انقلاب النيجر على
ليبيا اثر سيء جدا وده السؤال الاخير يا
محمود ليبيا الانفلات في ليبيا كان احد
اسباب الفوضى التي ضربت منطقه الساحل لانه
لم يكن الدوله المستقره وبتلعب دورا
ايجابي او سلبي في كل هذه المناطق فجاه
دوله ليبيا وقعت اصبح في فراغ سياسي كم
مهول من السلاح تسرب الى هذه الدول كم
كبير من الاموال خرج من ليبيا في ظروف
غامضه كم كبير من الجماعات المتطرفه مثلا
اللي كانت بتهرب من دوله تشاد مش لاقي
مكان يقويها وجدت ماوى لها في ليبيا
وبالتالي اثر سلبا على منطقه الساحل العكس
منطق النصر اذا حصلت فوده قد تزيد من
الفوضى الموجوده في ليبيا انا اشكر
حضراتكم احنا يعني انتهى وقت نا سريعا
ثلاث ملاحظات سريعه الملحوظه الاولانيه
انه نعتذر لو كان في مشكله في الصوت سوف
نتداركها الى المرات القادمه
الامر الثاني بعتذر كالعاده انه الوقت لم
يكفي لكل الاسئله بس لما بنكون بنتقابل كل
اسبوع اللي ما يلحقش سؤاله المره دي ان
شاء الله في المرات المقبله
فيما يتعلق
سؤال زميلنا او بعض الاصدقاء اللي الحوا
في حقيقه الموقف القانوني من الصحراء انا
سوف اعرضه ولو اني ما كنتش حابب ان
العمليه تبقى يعني ان انا اجر له ملف
بعينه ولكن اذا انا عرضته هيكون عرضي
برغبه مني في اجلاء كيف يرى المجتمع
الدولي قضيه الصحراء لاكثر ولا اقل اما
انا فلستد يعني انا مش عندي موقف محدد
تجاه هذه القضيه لان انا بتابع الشان
الدولي وما ليش موقف شخصي من كل قضيه اعرض
ما تقوله الواجهات الاطراف المختلفه من
قضيه معينه اشكركم ربنا يسعد ليلتكم
واراكم الاسبوع المقبل على خير ان شاء
الله